[Music]
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of boy spinning and
flowers to benefit your body and brain
and today
i am giving you a combo based around
contact poi which is something that i
never do before we dive in i just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckonen thank you
so very much for your support for my
work and my mission so i've done a lot
of combos on this channel in the past
few years and i am realizing that one of
the few things that i have never tackled
is a combo that is made up completely of
contact poi moves part of which being
that you know i think that my style is
not predominantly contact poi but it did
dawn on me that there was a gap there
that i could fill in now i think
technically you could kind of consider
this to be a drill that just involves
using similar contact roles on both
sides of the body but you know
i would also argue that there are some
combo elements to this too so
i don't know
give me i'm all good on this one maybe
the good news is though that you really
only need two poi tricks in order to get
this down
trick is you need to have them on both
sides of your body here are those two
tricks you need to have down inner arm
rolls that you can catch and then send
right back out to your palm
and you need to have outer forearm rolls
and specifically be able to transfer
those rolls from arm to arm
[Music]
i'll go ahead and leave links to
tutorials for both of these tricks down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching on youtube
i'll show you the combo full speed then
take you through it step by step before
finally showing to you again in slow
motion
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what are we dealing with
here well basically there's two things
number one is this
contact role here that involves just
kind of catching the poi as the tether
comes around and it wraps around our
arms like this now the added trick to
this of course is that as the poi comes
out the direction of that tether carries
it around to the other side of our body
we just transfer
one of these catches
over to the other side of the body just
by
you know handing off the head to the
other hand
in the grand scheme of things i don't
care if you hang out for a few beats on
either side to get yourself ready for
the roll and catch that's totally up to
you
but the transfer is important here
because after all the whole point of
this is to be able to do the same trick
in both hands right so the way i'm
thinking of this is that i do
a rolling catch on the right side bring
it out transfer to the left
i do a rolling catch on the left side
bring it out transfer it to the right
i'm going to go back and forth like that
twice and then on the
third time going through this
i'm instead just going to let the poi
exit so that i catch the tether instead
of catching it yeah and just the only
difference there is that instead of
having the tether at kind of an angle to
my arm i'm having it roll straight down
my arm and that just means that it
guides the poi to an exit spot right
next to my elbow and make sure that the
that the tether comes up right where my
hand is going to be waiting for it from
here you can use your preferred method
of choice to get into the forearm roll
maybe it is just doing the kind of uh
no beat throwing catch maybe you like me
prefer doing the isolated throw that
goes in the opposite direction and
automatically gives you the little click
on your uh
on your funny bone to let you know that
you're ready to do the roll but
either which way you do want to wind up
here where you've got the poi and cradle
in your right hand and you're ready to
do a contact roll with it now the
transfer is a little tricky because what
we're used to doing when we do that
outer forearm roll is just letting the
ball go off the edge of the elbow and of
course our hand is there to catch the
tether as it comes around the difference
here is that rather than making that
catch happen you want to make sure that
you have your other hand
basically sitting underneath your elbow
so that you can just drop the poi
down into the cradle for your opposite
hand from there you can
initiate another contact roll going down
your elbow
my preferred way of doing this honestly
is to try and keep the line of the
tether and the elbows
as
kind of solid as possible going through
this and the movement i'm doing with my
arms is like it's literally just
sneaking one underneath the other it's
almost like i'm stacking them one thing
that might not be obvious about how i'm
doing this is that my forearms are
actually kind of at angles to each other
so of course as the poi is rolling off
the edge of one elbow i've got the other
hand waiting right underneath there but
my forearms will always being kind of an
x like this as i'm doing this whether
it's my right hand on top or whether
it's my left hand on top so i'm doing
this transfer once
twice
three times and on the fourth i finally
exit and that's the end of the combo so
then the whole thing is i go ahead and
do
the inner catch once
i do
the inner catch twice
i do the inner catch
three times
transfer over to doing it a fourth
and i
then switch off doing the fifth time
exit out
catching cradle go back and forth once
twice
three times and on the fourth time
we exit and that's the whole combo let
me show that to you in slow motion
is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome so it's a little unorthodox i
know
and goodness knows me teaching a
combo that is nothing but contact poi is
a strange one but hopefully those of you
all out there who are working with
contact poi can still find something to
get out of this
and i also appreciate the fact that
contact poi is one of those things that
does not necessarily require any
previous knowledge of poi in order to do
it so technically speaking you can think
of this as a beginner combo but if you
decide to take the plunge and learn this
combo i would love it if you would post
a video of yourself doing it to social
media be it instagram youtube facebook
what have you and make sure to tag me i
am at drexfactor on all those different
platforms and i would love to see your
hard work if you share this combo to
your stories i will go ahead and copy it
over into my story so that all my
followers can see your hard work if you
got anything out of this video please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe both to help other people find
it as well as to help my channel grow
this video would not be possible were it
not for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like these videos do you like my
combo tutorials do you like my flow
sessions do you like my flow arts
culture vlogs i'm on a mission to try
and bring flow arts and poi spinning to
the wider world and help people connect
with their brains and their bodies as
creative individuals so help me out in
doing so head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signup you can do that
either at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in achieving this
mission so go check that out please and
thank you what did you all think of this
combo would you like me to try out more
contact poi combos in the future maybe
involving some more advanced tricks
leave me a comment and let me know and
in the meantime i will leave a link to a
playlist of other combo tutorials i have
done down in the description or you can
click the link that just popped up if
you are watching on youtube make sure to
get out and flow this weekend and i will
see you with a brand new video on monday
peace